well it's an honor to be here
uh on the stage
just after the leadership remarks we've
we heard from prime minister johnson
president biden and other distinguished
leader
leaders it was six years ago in paris
where i joined many of these leaders to
announce the first commitment
to developing the innovative
technologies needed to stop climate
change
today i'm thrilled to report
that that effort is going well
i committed to create breakthrough
energy to complement the commitment from
22 countries to increase
r d through mission innovation
bed
has so far
raised over 2 billion
and funded over 80 companies from 11
countries across
four continents
the progress in innovation has been very
exciting in fact it surprised me with
how well it's going
this progress
has meant that we've expanded
breakthrough energy now to cover the
area of technology deployment
in order to scale these innovations to
get to zero
we need to reduce the cost difference
between the current products and the
green products
a difference i call the green premium
the cost of transition must be low
enough
that the whole world can afford
it to make this happen
right through energy is added
catalyst catalyst
is the first of a kind effort
to build the big projects we need to
lower green premiums
and expand the market
for early stage critical climate
technologies
together with the incredible partners
listed here
catalyst will do four things
first is harness technical expertise to
understand the lowest cost path for
these innovations
second is connect government resources
with business expertise
finally
connect grants and equity
to be last mile financing
and fourth
to create
markets for investors thank you
by guaranteeing
that the green output
will have customers as we bring down
that green premium
with our private sector partners we now
have over one and a half billion
that we expect will leverage more than
ten times that amount
in public and private financing
this will support projects in four areas
and we're just getting started
over the next year i expect will more
than double
our financial strength
but of course mitigation
[Music]
is not our only
job here
even if we hit
the goal of net zero by 2050
we still
have to help particularly the developing
countries deal with the challenges of
climate
people are already impacted by
a warmer planet
these impacts will only get worse
especially for the world's poorest who
live near the equator
we will lose the global fight against
poverty if we don't help vulnerable
farmers adapt to climate change
for this reason the gates foundation is
proud to be a partner in the agriculture
innovation mission for climate
this new coalition was launched by the
united states and united arab emirates
and now has over 30 member countries
as part of our work with aim for ce
i'm committing the gates foundation to
provide an additional 315 million over
the next three years
to the cgiar
cgir is an amazing organization
that provides breakthrough seeds to
small holder farmers all over the world
all of us here today have a
responsibility and an opportunity to
deliver these solutions
together
we must drive
a green innovation revolution
one that stops climate change
protects vulnerable communities
and continues the world on a path to
progress